so Russell Brand plays the voice of a
rabbit that shit's candy always wanted
one of those
hop all right here we go
so hop is the story of the heir to the
Easter Bunny Empire voiced by Russell
Brand and an out-of-work guy played by
James Marsden who apparently is playing
James Marsden now hop you got a look at
a movie like this through a kids
perspective it's really not made for
people like me or us the movie has some
funny parts yeah but at a point when I
was watching the movie I was just like
this is what the trailer deferring
vengeance felt like the movie has some
funny parts and it has a really sweet
cameo because every time this guy cameos
from something is always winning but it
was like the most generic kids movie no
one freaks out when they see the rabbit
except James Marsden he meets the
talking rabbit freaks out like a normal
person would then they go to a diner and
they're eating in the rabbit orders
dessert he stalks the waitress responds
apparently she thinks it's normal that
is when you know you've been working
there too long James Marston was like
the biggest myth this is what
happens when you're in like 15 minutes
of x-men 3 even that is enough to kill
you I could have seen like anybody play
his role like David Spade Adam Sandler
James Marsden anyone could have played
the voice of the bunny also Russell
Brand is pretty funny and all in the
rabbit didn't have some funny stuff to
say but nothing stood out and the
soundtrack was really generic any time
something would happen or someone would
run from something it just sounded like
really generic Looney Tunes music not in
like an homage to Looney Tunes kind of
way but just in a really lazy soundtrack
kinda way I try to enjoy it I tried to
like it but ultimately I kept checking
my watch going holy it's only been
on for an hour that's bad news I'll say
it like this if you're a kid you're
gonna be thoroughly entertained with
this movie it's generic but you're not
going to care as an adult who has to sit
there with the kid you're going to want
to kill yourself so this is a perfect
movie to like drop the kids off at the
theater or with a babysitter or
something and then just I don't know
take a bubble bath life's hard we're in
a recession you deserve it if you're
under the age of 10 and you're watching
my videos shame on you please subscribe
you'll like the movie if you're over the
age of 10 so I'm going to give the adult
rating because I can't put my head into
a child's mind and I gotta say it's not
quite dog it's Easter Bunny
it's funny cuz II he shits jelly beans
it's like the Santa Claus with the
talking bunny in a really generic
plotline - the really annoying kid
apparently they're hitting all the
Hallmark holidays all that's left is
Valentine's Day in which some average
guy can be like the heir to the love
Empire and then can
the woman of his dreams and get married
and there you go then it can have a
smash sequel called took half my
but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more